[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera buonasera a tutti io sono qui
oggi per parlarvi di argomenti
scientifici argomenti accademici ma
soprattutto per parlargli delle delle
emozioni e di quello che come appunto
diceva anche giacomo è stato il mio
viaggio vi parlo delle emozioni e cerco
di trasmettere le anche perché essere
qui sopra un palco di fronte ad un
pubblico causa sempre delle emozioni
molto forti e io sono molto molto
emozionato e anche onorato oggi di far
parte di questo importante evento anche
per adesso
oggi vi voglio parlare della mia storia
che è una storia che eri in particolare
riguarda i diritti i diritti che spesso
e volentieri vengono anche negati
appunto alle persone vengono negati in
tantissimi frangenti quando si parla di
diritti in qualche modo si parte da
sempre dal concerto di cosa sia giusto
di cosa sia sbagliato e questo però
nasce sempre da un fortissimo senso di
soggettività
quindi nonostante ci sia un etica
condivisa nonostante ci possa essere una
morale riconosciuta tutto quello che
riguarda l'ambito di diritti purtroppo è
sempre alla mercé diari della
soggettività stessa quindi quando mi è
stato chiesto di parlare di un argomento
così vasto influente mi sono appunto
colta prima sentito un po perso
dopodiché ho cercato di
i collezionabili che sono state le mie
esperienze quelle che sono state le mie
ed emotività e soprattutto i miei
ricordi le emozioni che io mi ricordi mi
mi causavano e mi hanno causato quindi
la persona che poi hanno creato e che ha
di fronte a voi oggi spesso ci troviamo
davanti alle soprusi ed affermazioni
devastanti a discriminazioni di ogni
genere che portano appunto ad una lenta
erosione dei diritti e voglio darvi
subito un esempio proprio a partire
qui dalla nostra occidentali ma l'italia
di oggi vediamo però la formazione di
negazioni di nuovi diritti in quanto
tutto sommato possiamo trovare
situazioni ancora oggi anacronistiche
sento e spesso ho sperimentato proprio
anche sulla mia stessa belle in prima
persona con certi che nulla hanno a che
vedere con la visione umana e
antropologica della società e qui ancora
una volta vorrei portarvi subito un
esempio molto pratico in questi in
questi tempi per esempio vediamo e
sentiamo parlare sempre più
insistentemente della questione dei
migranti è una questione molto
importante
semplicemente perché le cose stanno
cambiando nel mondo ahimé non c'è
nessuno oggi che se ne occupi restiamo
ci sono tantissimi dati tantissimi studi
scientifici appunto che si dicono che
entro il 2030 2050 ci saranno milioni di
persone che si sposteranno da una parte
del mondo verso l'altra una su tutta
l'italia entro il 2050 sono previsti 40
milioni di persone 40 milioni di persone
considerando che in italia
sono 60 milioni sono davvero tanti però
purtroppo ancora nessuno appunto si
prende cura di queste cose
questo è un problema perché tutto
sommato quando si parla di persone che
si muovono si parla di persone che si
muovono sì per cambiamenti climatici ma
anche e soprattutto per l'assenza per la
latenza di diritti quindi
discriminazioni di genere di religione e
di orientamento sessuale lavorative e
tantissime altre
quindi siamo in qualche modo di fronte
ad una nuova epoca un po revival nel
senso che è come se quasi dopo quasi 10
mila anni ancora una volta l'uomo da
stanziale tornasse da nomade quindi come
succedeva ancora prima del del neolitico
e il solo oggi
ovviamente i confini sono diversi
l'identità sono diverse le culture sono
diverse sono molto più forti di allora
quindi riuscire a parlare di diritti
specialmente quando in questo caso
sull'ambito dei migranti le persone
sentono violate il proprio domicilio la
propria identità la propria cultura è
molto difficile e la politica in questo
momento sembra averne poca contezza per
cui quello che cercherò ancora di fare è
cercare di dirti quello che mi è
successo in qualche modo perché oggi
siamo siamo fuori tempo massimo in
qualche modo è ed è tempo di cominciare
ad alzare
testa di smetterla di guardarsi la punta
delle scarpe e sicuramente cominciare a
vedere quello che sta davanti a noi
perché è davanti a noi e non attende è
il momento non ci sono più parole da
sprecare
e come diceva il buon vecchio walt
disney
l'unico modo per cominciare e smettere
di parlare è sicuramente iniziano a fare
dobbiamo fare perché ciò che sta davanti
a noi e avanti come dicevo non attende
dobbiamo fare perché troppo spesso i
nostri diritti sono violati e neppure se
ne rendiamo conto
a tal proposito volevo condividere
ve l'ho già anticipato la mia storia
cioè quello che io ho fatto a proposito
del fare e su come oggi ancora oggi ai
noi
l'omosessualita stia navigando in acque
sempre molto agitate io sono sempre
stato un cane sciolto uno che spesso si
è distinto diciamo dalla massa ma non
perche volesse dimostrare qualcosa
perché avessi particolari meriti
assolutamente era solo per inclinazione
i miei amici andavano a ballare e io me
ne andavo a passeggiare per i boschi
miei amici andavano a metà da londra e
io me ne stavo a parigi
mia sorella studiava e aveva ottimi vuoi
che io facevo lo stretto indispensabile
come diceva baloo sul libro della
giungla
insomma mi sono sempre sentito diverso e
tutto sommato questa diversità io non
l'ho mai accettata
ho sempre vissuto e convissuto non senza
fatica senza disagio con dentro una
strana sensazione di tumulto qualcosa di
non detto qualcosa da tacere che non
rientrava poi negli schemi quelli con i
quali io ero cresciuto e nei quali
naturalmente mi riconoscevo perché
questa era quella società questa era la
società nella quale io vivevo e che mi
aveva in qualche modo cullato facevo
finta di niente per cui mi dicevo
passerà poi tornava la stessa sensazione
magari
davanti a quel ragazzo che mi piaceva
tanto e ero contento se mi sorrideva
persino quando magari mi spostava il
fumo in faccia della sua sigaretta per
darmi fastidio e tutto sommato non non
potevo accettarlo come avrei potuto come
avrei potuto dire prima me stesso e poi
ai miei genitori ai miei amici ai
parenti al mondo intero che mi piacevano
i ragazzi poi in un paesino di 6000
anime io vengo da un piccolo paese
vicino ad arezzo lo avrebbero saputo
tutti e sicuramente mi avrebbero de riso
o almeno questo era il mio pensiero non
conoscevo nessun altro poi tra l'altro
al tempo non conoscevo nessun altro
tranne me perché conoscere gli altri
tutto sommato era un modo per me di
espormi e non non era assolutamente il
caso di di espormi quindi mi sentivo
solo o piuttosto c'era lucio è quello
che io definisco il finocchio dentro di
me quindi eravamo in due ma una
situazione sicuramente dicotomica
diciamo poi succede che faccio le mie
prime esperienze di soppiatto facendo un
sacco di chilometri in aperta campagna
per sfuggire alla vergogna se qualcuno
mi avesse mai scoperto di quelle prime
esperienze e poi rimase solamente
l'amaro in bocca perché mi dicevano è
sbagliato non va bene e loro poi dopo
tutti sicily fidanza vano in maniera
eterosessuale ikeba vogliate rosoli è
vero fidanzati e per cui ancora una
volta mi dicevo passerà un giorno
anch'io avrò una moglie dei figli e quel
masso che mi sentivo nello stomaco
poi magari sarebbe scomparso non è stato
così
lasciate che vi racconti un po com'è
andata i primi approcci erano su
internet quando ancora internet prevede
valori conta scatti in casa quindi era
una situazione veramente
allucinante perché facevo ovviamente
tutto di nascosto ma questo maledetto
conta scatti continuava a scattare
quando io andavo a cercare su siti
esteri per esempio per cui le domande
inopportune dei miei genitori che mi
chiedevano ma come mai questo contatore
continua ad andare avanti ed io che
tutto sommato mi inventavo la passione
per le lingue estere tanto che poi alla
fine mi ci sono anche laureato e la
situazione era un po questa quindi anche
le prime conoscenze in qualche modo
sempre tramite la rete perché ragazzi
arezzo e arezzo non è sicuramente roma
quindi si conoscevano gente in rete
delle quali ovviamente diffidavo perché
erano delle mie parti quindi magari mi
conoscevano avrebbero potuto parlare e
le persone quindi più interessanti erano
sicuramente a chilometri di distanza e
per me erano approdi inarrivabili
semplicemente perché non avrei mai
potuto raccontare ai miei sto due giorni
fuori per chissà quale motivo non sono
poi mai stato troppo bravo a raccontare
le poesie amici di legge sempre in
faccia quando racconta le bugie
quindi arriva il giorno invece in cui in
cui mi decido
lui era un direttore d'orchestra
bellissimo affascinante e carismatico un
personaggio che è veramente mi invitava
anche mille attenzioni mi faceva un mi
faceva sentire unico che tra l'altro per
una persona comune ago spropositato come
il mio era completamente linfa vitale
una cosa del genere mi riempiva si di
attenzioni di telefonate
dopo tre mesi di telefonate e poi a
distanza il nulla e un po uno strumento
un gioco nelle
nelle sue mani e queste erano le mie
prime esperienze emotive del mio nuovo
mondo omosessuale
forse era l'amore però non avevo nessuno
ancora una volta con cui confrontarmi
ahimé se non il finocchio che era dentro
di me arrivano i 24 anni e ricordo che
il tutto quella tra tenere dentro mi
faceva ammalare quindi avevo puntate di
febbre a 40 tonsilliti psoriasi eruzioni
cutanee stomaco a pezzi e in una di
queste giornate di un po alla grey's
anatomy succede che alcuni miei amici
che avevo conosciuto vengono a trovarmi
a casa proprio perché stavo male e
quando ancora i miei non c'erano quasi
se ne stanno bene andare e rientrano
rientrano i miei rientra mia madre mia
sorella e mio cognato perché come è
stato detto prima
purtroppo poco tempo prima era anche
molto mio padre quindi la situazione
familiare era veramente molto molto
difficile e mia madre
dopo che i miei amici sono andati via
esclama che cosa ci fa quello in casa
nostra
e io dico che sono semplicemente dei
miei amici sono venuti a trovarmi perché
sto male lei
sinceramente mi reagisce in malo modo
dicendomi che non erano alle amicizie
giuste per me io le chiedo il perché che
ha successo
lei mi dice bene si fa che uno di loro è
[ __ ] e io le rispondo
va bene però ognuno fa la vita che vuole
fintanto che non dà fastidio agli altri
non vedo quale sia il problema
e lei mi dice effettivamente degli altri
non mi interessa però di mio figlio si
io ancora non avevo il coraggio anche se
stavo prendendo la palla in mano le
rispondo dopo un quarto di secolo che mi
ha in casa forse qualcosa
potresti aver capito da quel giorno è
stato diciamo un cominciato un periodo
piuttosto drammatico perché mi sentivo
ripudiato anche dalla mia stessa
famiglia
cominciamo ad avere gli asciugamani
separati rispetto agli altri
me ne mangiamo in disparte c'erano tutte
situazioni in casa mia che mi mettevano
a profondo disagio addirittura mia madre
utilizzava delle parole nei miei
confronti che non avevo mai sentito mai
sentito uscire dalla sua bocca per cui
ero erano sconvolto tra lo stesso tempo
ero sollevato perché finalmente io lo
avevo detto finalmente lei lo sapevo non
lo accettava inveiva si domandava anche
lei come come sarebbe andata avanti la
sua vita com'è possibile che l'unico
uomo rimasto in casa sua fosse
omosessuale
il paese lo avrebbe saputo lei avrebbe
dovuto difendersi diciamo da
da questo tipo di accuse per cui è stato
un periodo molto difficile ciononostante
gli e ne rendo merito mia madre è una
persona meravigliosa e quindi è stata
anche la prima poi ad invitare a cena
quello che sarebbe stato poi il mio
ragazzo e vi racconto un po come ci
siamo conosciuti con il mio primo
ragazzo la mia prima storia importante
un giorno stavo passeggiando per via
petrarca una strada qua di arezzo e
dovevo portare in tribunale dei
documenti per l'azienda per cui lavoravo
mentre passeggiavo a un certo punto noto
un ragazzo interessante quindi ci
scambiamo praticamente sullo stesso
marciapiede e ogni volto verso di lui
per guardarlo perché comunque era un bel
ragazzo e lui si era voltato quindi
ansia panico
dopodiché mi rivolto per la mia strada
mi riporto ancora una volta e vedo che
si era portata un'altra volta anche lui
quindi mi dico ma com'è possibile una
cosa del genere ad arezzo in centro in
pieno giorno neanche in un film di
ospite che succederebbe una cosa del
genere per cui attraverso la strada e mi
fermo al primo barra che che mi capita a
tiro prende un caffè per rilassarmi
proprio per le mozioni un attimo che che
mi era presa e lo vedo di passare
davanti alle vetrine del bar per cui
finiscono mio caffè pago riesco fuori
dal bar guarda a destra guarda a
sinistra non lo vedevo più per cui se
n'è andato riprendo la mia strada e nel
mentre che stavo è stato continuando la
mia strada dal lato opposto lo vedo lo
guardo lui mi guarda mi sorride a quel
punto io ho deciso di attraversare la
strada e gli dico ciao ti va di
accompagnarmi in tribunale lui mi guarda
esterrefatto e dice anche no
dopo di che cominciò appunto a spiegarvi
un po perché stavo perché stava andando
in tribunale e camminando
durante quelle centinaia di metri
parliamo di chi siamo parliamo delle
nostre passioni scopriamo di avere la
fotografia come passione comune e gli
parlò anche di uno dei miei libri
preferiti che si chiama lettere dalla
chiesa di silvano agosti che consiglio a
tutti voi tra l'altro perché è veramente
una bellissima esperienza di vita
utopica ma anche reale tutto sommato
degli lascia una passione che dura ben
nove anni e che ci ha portato a stare
insieme appunto nove anni 9 anni di
storia tra due uomini in cui una volta
che avevo accanto a me la persona che
amavo non mi sono più sentito
impenitente e non ho avuto più alcuna
remora nel paese aree il mio
orientamento sessuale nonostante lui più
grandi di me ha addirittura di 10 anni
ancora non l'avesse detto quasi a
nessuno
allora mi sono sentito più libero ho
cominciato a introdurlo all'interno
della mia famiglia alla mia famiglia
fortunatamente rispetto a tante altre
situazioni
lo ha appena accolto accettato e amato
probabilmente quanto me l'ho fatto
sentire normale perché lui non si
sentiva normale perché noi siamo normali
tuttora e non avevo più paura per me
questo era diventato un traguardo e
quindi a chiunque mi chiedesse in
aretino allora la città non ce l'hai
città eccetto in aretino significa
ragazzi e ragazze io rispondevo no sul
sito va bene uguale allora lì che mi
sentivo più forte perché finalmente non
vedevo più negli sguardi delle persone
la discriminazione li vedevo interdetti
balbuzienti per cui era veramente per me
aver raggiunto un obiettivo ed ho visto
anche l'umanità né in quelli che erano i
miei amici quelli veri che pensavo mi
avessero poi mensione un angolo perché
ero diverso ed invece fortunatamente non
è stato così
è così che poi ho smesso di
procrastinare è così che mi sono reso
conto di cosa voglia dire vivere di
nascosto perché la cultura diffusa nel
tuo paese ancora ancorata concerti
medievali purtroppo è invece di
esprimere solidarietà ed umanità spesso
e volentieri si percorre la strada
appunto della discriminazione
ciononostante come al solito ho voluto
fare di testa mia e sono andato dritto
per la mia strada
quindi ho detto sono gay
se per voi le etichette sono importanti
sono un uomo se invece per voi sono
importanti le parole per il loro
significato ci sono alcuni dati che poi
mi hanno in qualche modo rassicurato in
questo percorso c'è un'indagine istat
del 2012 dal quale risulta che il tabù
sull'omosessualità sembra molto
ridimensionato e molto meno presente
nella società
al contrario di quanto accade invece tra
quelli che siedono in parlamento solo un
quarto circa degli intervistati ancorato
ancora vecchi pregiudizi che considerano
l'omosessualità una malattia sinonimo di
moralità minaccia per la famiglia mentre
per ben due terzi degli italiani ci sono
persone convinte che l'amore prescinda
dal sesso di coloro che ne sono
coinvolti personalmente ho avuto la
fortuna di non essere mai discriminato
nei luoghi di lavoro anche se non so
cosa sarebbe veramente successo visto
che nei lavori precedenti rispetto a
quello che faccio attualmente ancora non
avevo fatto coming out
sicuramente avrei fatto un casino perché
io di solito come ho sempre fatto
combatto molto per la libertà di
espressione che tra l'altro è anche un
diritto costituzionale quindi mi sembra
il minimo indispensabile
ed è proprio per questo per questa mia
attitudine che ho cominciato anche tra
le tante che ho sempre fatto in vita mia
a far parte del comitato locale di tihar
cigarini col quale ho fatto di tutto
dall'organizzazione di eventi anche
addirittura il ballerino su palco senza
però vergognarmene cercando di capire
perché è sempre stata la curiosità che
mi ha spinto a a vivere anche questa
nuova dimensione
io non amo i pregiudizi e credo che una
valutazione per non essere un
pregiudizio debba nascere da un esame
interno piuttosto che sostituirsi ad
esso come spesso ho fatto in vita mia ho
investito il mio tempo le mie energie e
anche le mie emozioni all'interno
dell'associazione che hai nel come
spesso accade in italia purtroppo è un
po ideologicamente politicizzata
ciononostante siamo andati avanti perché
nonostante tutto siamo nel 2017 ed avere
un paese ancora in cui non ci sono leggi
contro l'omofobia
mancano dei matrimoni ugualitari non c'è
la possibilità di riconoscere la
genitorialità affitti e compagni delle
persone lgbt che le persone che poi si
scelgono per la vita
tanto più che poi dopo queste sono tutte
cose che vanno a discapito anche dei
bambini stessi in questo caso in
moltissime parti del mondo questo già
succede
e questi diritti sono già garantiti e
non c'è stata alcuna catastrofe sociale
causata da alcuna teoria gender o
concetti palio scientifici questo
siatene sicuri
spesso ci troviamo si trovano si trovano
contrapposizioni ideologiche tra
l'omosessualità e anche la religione ma
religioni se andiamo a vedere
quello che significa etimologicamente io
sono un linguista in qualche modo
significare leggere avere riguardo e
cura per qualcosa quindi come cittadino
o diritti e doveri e ho il dovere di
pagare le tasse il mio impegno per
questo piano riconoscimento sarà
costante le lotte per il voto alle donne
contro l'apartheid i movimenti dispongo
lì ci disegnano questo ci insegnano che
nel riconoscimento reciproco che una
comunità crea forme sinergiche e avanza
culturalmente perché quando non si
capisce qualcosa che dobbiamo fare uno
sforzo e youtube accendere le sinapsi e
cercare di comprendere nel duplice senso
di capire ed accogliere solo così saremo
sicuri che ogni nuova legge sarà a
favore dell'intera società e non a
scapito di una sola parte
queste parole lasciatemi dire vogliono
esprimere la necessità che sia del
riconoscimento reciproco in un mondo
quello attuale fatto di divergenze e
collisioni culturali
in sostanza in sostanza usando le parole
di harvey milk
se non ti mobiliti per difendere i
diritti di qualcuno che in quel momento
ne ha privato
quando poi intaccheranno i tuoi nessuno
si muoverà per te
ed è questo il punto questo è ciò che fa
di una collettività di persone una
società organizzata e l'offesa
[Applauso]
[Musica]